avant la guerre j'étais un jeune
militaire de carrière idéaliste dans
l'eure la tradition la patrie j'y
croyais à tous un chalumeau bon vent
le chef d'escadron l'entier du breizh
chargé de juger notre affaire je
comprends pas qu'un titre qu'a reçu la
légion d'honneur puis s'est rendu
coupable de ce qui lui est reproché
aujourd'hui
j'imagine que vous étiez ivre je sais
pas où je regrette rien
[Musique]
et personne n'obligera m'excuser vous le
connaissiez vous ce mort l'un qui avant
son coup d'éclat à drôle de type
quand je n'ai vu passer le 14 juillet
avec son chien j'étais loin de me douter
la suite
j'avais créé avec cette bête une
relation de compagnons d'armes
je veux pas pousser cahier ça c'est faux
[Musique]
ce que j'ai fait c'est contre les
profiteurs qu'envoyer de se faire fuir
leur place
pour ça il faudrait qu'il s'excuse il en
refusait d'insulter la nation c'est
inacceptable je suis beaucoup trop
données grecques s'obstine à vouloir
être condamné
un supplice sur 10 plus qui reviennent
son fils aymon l'attend
héroïsme la bravoure le patriotisme
encore des malheureux qui croit en ses
conneries
la justice est là pour protéger la
société la protégée de cheap
qui est coupable qui est innocent c'est
qu'on a ne fait que là il fait une
grande injustice savez de quoi on
l'accuse allait diffuser mois
[Musique]
la guerre que les hommes en clair la
nature
tout s'est passé le 14 juillet 1919 sur
la grand place
[Musique]
si tu veux qu'ils sortent tu le fais
comprendre qu'il doit s'excuser comme ça
pour partir en sang